today on the Matt Walsh show major
medical organizations called the doj to
arrest and imprison those of us who
criticize their medical practices also
female athletes at a school in Vermont
are banned from the locker room because
they don't want to get naked in front of
a boy Candice Owens and Kanye West are
of trouble by wearing shirts with a very
controversial message White lives matter
you can't say that leftist activists
make their counter-insurgency battle
plans for my what is a woman's screening
tour and in our daily cancellation two
gay men say they have a right to be
biological parents how does that work
exactly we'll find out today that and
much more on that Wall's show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
's infrastructure bill that Congress
passed last year where here's something
that I bet you didn't know about it in a
few years every car might be required to
come with a safety device that passively
monitors you for impaired driving big
government wants to control every part
of your life and clamp down on your
digital Freedom that's why I use
expressvpn to protect my network from
being monitored your internet provider
can keep logs of your internet activity
which includes things like the sites you
visited and how much time you spent on
them but when you use expressvpn your
internet activity is shielded their app
works by rerouting 100 of your network
data through their secure encrypted
servers to keep your activity private
unlike the kill switch the government
wants to put in all of our cars
expressvpn's kill switch actually
protects you if your VPN protection
connection ever drops network data is
immediately stopped from entering or
leaving your device to keep your privacy
from being compromised it's a kill
switch that you control so stop letting
the government spy on you take back your
privacy and your freedom at expressvpn
n.com Walsh and get three months for
free that's exp r e s s vpn.com Walsh to
get this special offer for my listeners
expressvpn.com Welsh
yesterday the American Academy of
Pediatrics along with the American
Medical Association and the Children's
Hospital Association collectively
published a letter which was addressed
to the Department of Justice
and which calls for me to be prosecuted
and thrown in federal prison so just
another day at the office I suppose but
it's not just me being targeted of
course lives of tick tock Chris rufo and
others are all are are on The Hit List
and the letter doesn't mention Us by
name but it doesn't have to besides
there's always the media which is here
to sort of fill in the blanks for them
which they rely on so as the hill
reports quote leading Healthcare
organizations and sent a letter uh
Monday to attorney general Merrick
Garland and called on the Department of
Justice to investigate recent threats of
violence against Physicians hospitals
and families that provide gender
affirming care to transgender youth the
organizations collectively represent
more than 270 000 positions and more
than 220 Children's Hospitals Nationwide
medical facilities that provide gender
affirming Healthcare to transgender
minors have recently been the targets of
online attacks and the letter says a few
high-profile users are intentionally
spreading false and misleading
information conservative commentators
including Tucker Carlson and Matt Walsh
as well as right-wing social media
accounts with large followings lives of
tick tock have alleged that doctors are
abusing children by prescribing puberty
blockers and gender affirming hormones
now notice the verbiage there first of
all we have uh we're we're told that
we've alleged
that doctors are abusing children by
prescribing puberty blockers and gender
affirming hormones
so which part is alleged that doctors
are prescribing these drugs or that
they're abusing children by prescribing
the drugs so as always the phrasing is
intentionally vague and misleading and
also false we should we should know we
are not alleging that doctors are giving
sterilization and castration drugs to
kids they're doing more than that too
they're mutilating kids physically
through surgery we're not alleging that
we're reporting it we're observing it
we're uh we're pointing it out
it is a fact that this is happening and
we are calling attention to the fact
we're also not alleging that these drugs
constitute abuse again this is a fact
according to any coherent definition of
the word abuse we are um arguing that
this practice is abusive and we are
presenting evidence and information to
support that claim
but we know of course that the other
side will not honestly engage with us
because they cannot they can only lie
and mislead and if that fails they can
call upon their powerful friends to have
a silence which brings us to the actual
letter which begins quote
dear attorney general Garland on behalf
of the American Academy of Pediatrics
the American Medical Association and the
Children's Hospital Association
collectively representing more than 270
000 positions and more than 220
Children's Hospitals we write to urge
you to investigate the organization's
individuals and entities coordinating
provoking and carrying out bomb threats
and threats of personal violence against
children's hospitals and Physicians
across the U.S so take special note of
the words individuals and provoking now
if they had simply called upon the doj
to investigate the people carrying out
the alleged bomb threats
I'd have no complaint about that yes if
there's a bomb threat investigate it
but they also want the federal
government to bring the hammer down on
the individuals who they claim are
provoking these alleged threats
and it's already been made very clear
that anyone who reports on what these
hospitals are doing or criticizes them
for or says that they should not be
doing what they're doing
is inciting violence even if they never
call for violence or say anything that
could be remotely construed as an
encouragement for violence just by
talking about it they are inciting
violence so it's clear who's being
referred to here now continuing from
Boston to Akron to Nashville to Seattle
Children's Hospitals academic Health
Systems and Physicians are being
targeted and threatened for providing
evidence-based Health Care these attacks
have not only made it difficult and
dangerous for institutions of practices
to provide this care they've also
disrupted many other services to family
seeking care these coordinated attacks
threaten federally protected rights to
health care for patients and their
families the attacks are rooted in an
intentional campaign of disinformation
where a few high-profile users on social
media share false and misleading
information targeting individual
Physicians and hospitals resulting in a
rapid escalation of threats harassment
and disruption of care across multiple
jurisdictions organizations have called
on technology companies to do more to
prevent this practice on digital
platforms and we now urge your office to
take Swift action to investigate and
prosecute all organizations individuals
and entities responsible
well there it is high profile users on
social media are targeting hospitals
which results in threats this is
happening in places like Boston and they
mentioned Nashville
they say these individuals should be
investigated and prosecuted and this is
all according to three of the largest
and wealthiest medical organizations in
the entire world so make no mistake here
they are explicitly stating that
high-profile people quote unquote who
criticize their practices
should go to federal prison
that's what you're asking for when you
when you're asking for the federal
government to arrest somebody
um they're not just saying that it
should happen they're actively calling
on the Attorney General to make it
happen
they intend to use the force of the
federal government
to silence us permanently if they can
so let me make a few points here
first of all we are once again accused
of sharing false and misleading
information to use their phrasing and
yet once again they fail to provide any
specific example of this supposed
misinformation
so I've been told a million times that
what I'm saying is misinformation will
live with Tick Tock of saying his
misinformation Chris rufo everybody what
we're all saying is misinformation no
one's ever specified what exact part is
misinformation
they don't do that because they know
Phil full well that everything we've
reported about these hospitals is
factual and supported by extensive
documentation and evidence We Lay It All
Out
they also know full well that we're not
saying anything that these medical
establishments have not already said
themselves so the hospitals say we
provide these services and then we say
uh look these hospitals just said they
provide these services
and then we get accused of
misinformation
the real misinformation here is the
claim that we are spreading
misinformation
that itself is misinformation it's also
defamatory
okay the AAP and the AMA they are lying
about us with the direct and explicit
intent of causing us harm
that's defamation second
um I'm I'm obviously well aware that the
people who go around all day crying
about fascism and tyranny really have no
idea what these terms mean nor do they
care
but if we were living in some alternate
reality where such people had integrity
then maybe they'd be concerned about
this actual real life example of
authoritarian tyranny happening in their
midst because to State again these
extraordinarily well-funded and Powerful
medical organizations are attempting to
use the arm of the state to suppress
intimidate and punish their critics and
not just the state
see we see here the whole multi-headed
Hydra monstrosity come into view this is
the medical establishment summoning the
federal government and also uh the big
Tech Monopoly to crush anyone who
opposes it
and in this effort they also get a big
assist from the corporate media so this
is the uh this is the system the
corporate media the government medical
establishment big Tech
this is the system it's the thing the
left used to pretend to Rage Against
um yesterday there was a woman named
Brooke binkowski who's the managing
editor of a sham fact-checking outfit
and she tweeted at me in support of the
aap's speech impression tactic she said
freedom of speech isn't freedom from
consequences for that speech that's the
part you Bootleggers always forget until
it's too late cry more
yet of course the medical establishment
is trying to get the state involved
and Free Speech does most certainly mean
that your speech should be free from
government reprisal if that's not what
Free Speech means Then I then I don't
know what Free Speech means
which is what people like uh you know
that's what people like Brooke really
really mean by the way they don't think
that Free Speech means anything they
don't care about they're too cowardly to
say it
but it's her usage of the term boot
licker that really interests me because
she is here coming to the defense of the
federal government the medical
establishment big Tech and the corporate
media she is defending all of the most
powerful institutions in our society and
while doing so accusing me of being a
bootlicker
no I'm not I'm I'm the one that they are
trying to stomp under their Boot Hill
okay me and anyone else that opposes
what the medical establishment is doing
to kids we're the ones being stumped or
or that they're attempting to stop
she is the one kneeling and kissing
their feet
she and everybody else on the left
they uh Rage Against the Machine these
days by bowing before it
but will they be successful
the AAP wants Garland's goons to break
down our doors and cart us away in the
middle of the night at gunpoint and um
is that actually going to happen
maybe I mean you can't rule it out
it's exactly what they just did to that
pro-life activists up in Pennsylvania
and if they'll do it on that issue to a
guy like that
um then they'll do it here so you know
it's it is possible I will say that so
it's certainly a possibility
I can't control that or predict it
but what I can say is this what I've
been saying all along
which is that I truly believe that
gender ideology is one of the greatest
evils in human history
I don't say that lightly it's what I
actually that's that's what I believe
um and I believe that those of us who
are in this fight are called to be here
this is our vocation this is our mission
there's nothing they could threaten
that would make me back down from this
fight you're gonna have to throw me in
prison or kill me because that's the
only way you'll shut me up
I would actually rather be dead than
surrender to this madness
for me it's as simple as that
now let's get to our five headlines
thank you
this is from fox17.com it says girls
high school volleyball team
um a girl high school volleyball team
has reportedly been banned from its own
locker room after some players objected
to allowing a transgender player to be
present while the team was changing
clothes
in Vermont the home of Randolph High
School State policy dictates that
transgender students can play sports and
use facilities that correspond to their
desired gender the state law allows for
Trans students to play on Randolph
High's girls volleyball team and
apparently use the team's locker rooms
at the same time as everybody else
adding to this the trans athlete
allegedly made an inappropriate remark
to other players on the team while they
were all changing which made some
uncomfortable
one student who spoke with the news
Outlet claimed that the issue had become
a school-wide controversy quote it's a
huge thing everyone's asking so why
aren't you allowed in the locker room as
according to Blake Allen one of the
effective volleyball players my mom
wants me to do this interview to try to
make a change I feel like for stating my
opinion that I don't want a biological
man changing with me that I should not
have harassment charges or bullying
charges they should all be dropped
Allen claims that several other students
and some parents have raised complaints
about allowing the transgender athlete
inside the girls locker room those
concerns were all reportedly shot down
by the school officials who pointed to
state law which says transgender
athletes are allowed to use whichever
locker room they wish one parent who
spoke with the daily signal was
reportedly bewildered that the school
would prioritize the transgender
students needs over their daughters
quote we allowed a child who's
biologically the opposite sex male to go
in a locker room were biologically girls
were getting fully changed the
biological child was not changing and
sat in the back and watched girls
getting changed
that made girls feel uncomfortable made
girls feel violated and not protected
yeah I should think so
in response to the complaints Randolph
High said in a letter to parents that it
has plenty of space for students who
feel uncomfortable with the laws may
change in privacy
so that's what we're saying to the girls
not to the not to the boy
who's claiming that his gender identity
needs uh require him to change in a
locker room with girls not even change
reportedly just sit there and watch them
get changed so we can't say to him you
know there's plenty of other facilities
if you want to you know you could change
somewhere else you don't need to change
it we're not going to say it to him
we'll say that to all the girls who feel
uncomfortable
say to the girls oh if you don't want to
get naked in front of this guy that's
your problem you're the one with an
issue
you can go somewhere else
um in response to the compliance
Randolph High sent a letter to parents
that and it said that it has uh plenty
of space could we read that Alan
contests that the school's statement and
its apparent solution of using more
private areas such as bathroom stalls to
change simply aren't feasible
Allen said they want all the girls who
feel uncomfortable so pretty much 10
girls to get changed in a single stall
bathroom which would take over 30
minutes where if one person got changed
separately would take a minute no extra
time
so you could have 10 girls take turns
with one stall in a bathroom getting
changed and that is the solution they
came up with rather than saying to the
one guy you get changed in the stall
um
the the girls have said they don't have
any issue with the Trans athlete playing
on their team but they don't want the
transgender person in the locker room
whether where they're changing
especially given the inappropriate
remark that the person allegedly made
um
and then it continues uh the volleyball
team has has been banned from the locker
room by the school with officials saying
in an email announcement that they do
not make this decision lightly but we
believe it's the right decision at this
time
Vermont the Vermont agency of Education
policy says the use of restrooms and
locker rooms by transgender students
requires schools to consider numerous
factors a transgender student should not
be required to use a locker room or
restroom that conflicts with the
student's gender identity
uh
you know I'm sometimes tempted to draw
historical analogies
and to compare all of this to other
previous examples of you know Mass
hysteria Mass Insanity that you see
throughout history but this is really on
a different level because and and it
defies comparison in so many ways
um
other incidents of mass hysteria for one
thing are much more contained they're
more localized the Salem witch trials
for example and um and oftentimes
they're much shorter in duration
sort of these weird blips on the
historical radar so there was uh it was
something called the dancing plague of
1518 and I don't know a whole lot about
it but I don't think anyone really does
what I do know is that in 1518 and it's
some Village in the Roman Empire I think
in modern day France dozens of people
just townspeople started dancing and
they danced for weeks and nobody knew
why they were dancing and some of them
like danced themselves to death
and it was thought at the time that they
were demonically possessed now it's
theorized that they were sick or I think
one theory is that they had food
poisoning which makes you dance I've you
know I've had food poisoning before I've
been a Burger King like some of the
other people uh it's never caused me to
dance
in fact I I would rather get food
poisoning that makes me vomit my guts
out for for uh two days than have food
poisoning that makes me dance anyway
that's one Theory another theory is that
it was you know some sort of psychotic
episode that they all were having at the
same time personally I prefer the
contemporaneous explanation of demonic
possession makes more sense to me but
either way
these things are similar to The
transgender craze that is inflicting our
society right now in that they are
bizarre irrational
um that cause people to completely lose
their grip on reality
and also the the transgender craze like
the dancing epidemic or the Salem Witch
Trials
um will be looked back on by history as
a mystery a period of time that requires
explanation
but can never really be explained
that's what you have to realize about
what we're living through right now that
we are living in a in a chapter of the
history books one of those chapters
where people are going to be trying to
explain it like that's going to be the
main
uh topic of conversation for historians
of the Futures how did that happen
exactly
and yet this is different it's far worse
because it's much wider spread
it encompasses all of Western
Civilization
it's been going on for years
and the consequences are far more dire
far more dire
but it's still massive Theory
intentionally orchestrated
but Mass Hysteria
and now we have girls getting kicked out
of their locker rooms for not wanting to
be naked around a boy who is also
sexually harassing them allegedly
and even if he wasn't saying anything
just his very presence is sexual
harassment
I mean that's what we used to all agree
I thought
that if you are
um you know interjecting yourself
into a situation and where a girl does
not want you there doesn't consent to it
um in her private space where she's
vulnerable and you know taking her
clothes off and you show up and she
doesn't want you there your very
presence is harassment
we used to all agree and the sane and
rational Among Us still agree it's just
that we're a dwindling minority
unfortunately
being sane and rational I mean
by the way Caitlyn Jenner was on Fox to
talk about this and uh and I saw this
because this was trending on social
media this morning Caitlyn Jenner was
training for this let's
let's check that out here it is the left
is hijacked and politicized yet another
minority group in our wonderful country
that could hold USFA and this time again
it's trans people
um as a result of their radical left and
their use of identity politics agenda
they're really driving this country
apart I thought Joe Biden was supposed
to be the great unifier and all they're
doing is driving in this apart now does
this trans girl have the right under
Vermont law to be on the team and to use
the the locker room yes she does do
these girls have the right to comment
and tell the school board how
uncomfortable they are being in a locker
room with basically a biological boy
with a penis absolutely they do and
what is the school's solution to this
well let's ban the 10 girls uh who
complain the complainers put them off in
the corner in their own little part of
the locker room and don't do anything
when it comes to the this trans person
right so honestly everything is out of
whack right now so and these things have
to stop
everything's out of whack I agree so
it's it's so out of whack that this male
who identifies as a woman is being
trotted out onto TV
to be the voice of reason
and is celebrated by many on the right
in that role but but Jenner is not
suited for the position of the voice of
reason this is like
um the worst possible person actually
that you could bring in to talk about
this would be Caitlyn Jenner but of
course what they think as well this is a
trans person it's a perfect see we we
get credit from the left because we're
it's a trans person saying all this
Jenner is part of the problem okay it
was Jenner winning Woman of the Year in
2015 or whenever that was
who did perhaps more than anyone else
currently alive on the planet to bring
transgenderism into the mainstream you
know our the the the the the
at least the the final move into the
mainstream
was brought about
largely by
Caitlyn Jenner
who used to be Bruce Jenner
that was a that was a a pivotal moment
in history and again historians looking
back on that they're going to point to
that moment not the beginning of the
transgender craze uh but even so a
pivotal moment of bringing it into the
mainstream
and it's not like Jenner has repented of
that or said you know what I was wrong
about all that I wish I wasn't a part of
that no not at all
and now we get these Fox segments
but generous position makes no sense
okay is the biological and of course
they don't they don't ask they don't ask
this but is
is the biological male
a girl or not Jenner says uh this you
know this person who's who's basically a
biological male no not basically a
biological male it's a biological male
so here's the biological male a girl or
not
if he's a girl as Jenner says then yes
he would have the right to use the
girl's locker room in fact if he was a
girl and hadn't done anything else so
let's say that the sexual harassment uh
the inappropriate remarks that are
alleged didn't actually happen so it's
just a girl using the locker room not
doing anything wrong
and those other girls decided to be mean
and demand that he'd be kicked out uh
because he's not cool or something
then it would be the right decision
to tell the other girls that they should
leave instead of him
if he was actually a girl but he's not
see the one single the the only argument
against quote trans girls in the girls
locker room is that they are not girls
that is the only argument it's the only
one it's a good argument it's the only
argument you need but it's also the only
argument
if we're not right about that if we are
not correct that trans girls are not in
fact girls then we're wrong about the
whole thing but we are correct obviously
there is no other argument so Jenner
wants to affirm the girlness of this boy
referring to him as a trans girl and yet
still maintain that the other girls are
also correct well you know they're
they're both right no one's wrong here
no no it's this is a situation where you
have diametrically opposed points of
view and only one person can be right
it's impossible for them both to be
right
and instead of getting someone on the
segment to just explain this and
actually speak some truth we get Caitlyn
Jenner
but it doesn't say anything by the way
really oh the whole segment just amounts
to it well bro we got this situation
this is happening over here that's
happening over there yeah it's a big
mess
oh thanks Caitlin very insightful we we
really are grateful for your Insight yet
again
all right daily wire reports this uh one
day after wearing a white lives matter
shirt with daily wire host Candace Owens
in Paris Kanye West declared the black
lives matter movement over West and
Owens shock social media when the duo
Don the White lives matter shirt Each of
which also included a picture of the
Pope's face on the front
while flanked by models and matching
tops I didn't okay I never saw the front
of the shirt I saw the back so there's
the Pope
face on the front with models and
matching tops
I can't quite connect the dots on that
one but that's all right everyone knows
the black lives matter was a scam Wes
said on Instagram where he was near
where he has nearly 18 million followers
uh now it's over you're welcome the BLM
movement has opposed law enforcement
while promoting other radical ideas uh
as we know okay so
the White lives matter thing
um uh with our very own Candace Owens
has been a big topic of conversation and
people are very upset
as you can imagine
um we don't have to go through the whole
rundown in fact I just saw I mean
there's there's so many examples of this
we read them all but I just saw someone
posted it was a a fashion designer
uh I don't even I don't know which one
not that I can name any fashion
designers who said that this was a
traumatic it was a traumatic moment in
all of our lives for Candace Owens and
Kanye West to wear a shirt that says
white lives matter
um and lots of stuff like that it's
dangerous it's traumatic
uh Jameel hill hill tweeted so many
folks are trying to excuse Kanye wearing
a white lives matter t-shirt as just a
troll move or marketing maybe it is but
it's a dangerously dumb message to send
for someone with his massive platform
I've been off dude
I've been off dude
I don't know what that means I've been
off I was supposed to be a Commodore
I've been off dude
I've been off dude
oh I've been okay so she has been off
she's been off this guy it's like she
doesn't like him does that
so what it means okay
but y'all go ahead labeling his
foolishness as genius
um and then I responded to that I said
yes it's so incredibly dangerous to say
that a white man a white person's life
matters we know that you would never
make such a claim Jamil you despise
white people which is why you're morally
Superior thank you for enlightening us
once again a little bit of sarcasm there
I admit but she responded I want you to
pay attention to this response okay now
remember she originally said that it's
it's not only dumb but dangerous it's
dangerous to say that white lives matter
she responded to me she says you truly
don't have the range for this the reason
we don't have to say White lives matters
because White lives have never not
mattered the default position in this
country is white equals worthiness
the same has never been true for black
people you're welcome
now I want you to notice what she did
there because this is always what
happens right this is always what
happens
um
she Retreats from her claim without
admitting that's what that's what she's
doing
because she does in a very uh defiant
kind of way and it acts like she's you
know like she's dropping the mic but she
actually retreated completely from her
claim because she originally said it's
dangerous
to claim the White lives matter and then
in response to me she says it's just
it's not necessary it's redundant
because White lives matter and everyone
knows it so you don't need to say that
well those are two different things okay
um it's a redundant unnecessary message
is not the same as a dangerous message
in fact a redundant unnecessary message
cannot be dangerous it's it's redundant
it's unnecessary how can it how can it
be dangerous and also redundant and
unnecessary
what she's what she's claiming in her
follow-up is that well it's everyone
knows that white lives matter it's so uh
inherently understood that it's we don't
even need to say it
well if we all have this on an inherent
understanding and everyone knows then
how can it be dangerous to just say it
out loud the worst it could be is
redundant and unnecessary
no it can only be dangerous
there's only one way
only one way that a message can be
dangerous and there can be dangerous
messages
here's a dangerous message to say to a
boy uh you could be a girl
that's a dangerous message very
dangerous
so I'm not here saying that uh words can
never be dangerous they can you say that
to a child those are words it's very
dangerous
but the only way a message can be
dangerous is if it's not true
okay if the message the uh the the the
the statement the the Declaration is
true
it can't be dangerous
so if you are saying that it's dangerous
you are saying that it's not true which
which means that you are saying that you
don't agree that white lives matter
which is what she really means
so what she said the first time is what
she means is what they all mean
anyone out there saying White lives
matter is dangerous what they all really
mean is that they don't agree with it
they don't think that white lives matter
at least they don't matter as much as
black lives do and uh and and so it's
dangerous to say it because in their
mind there's a racial hierarchy in our
society that they've worked very hard to
uh to build and when you go around
especially as a as a black man and a
black woman saying White lives matter
well that that throws the whole
hierarchy out of balance
makes everything out of whack in Caitlyn
Jenner's words
so that's their actual problem
and this is all uh you know just leading
aside the fact that the what she's what
the claim that white lives have never
not mattered in this country is of
course uh not true
um in fact
the very the very fact that it's
considered dangerous to say White lives
matter
means that white lives are not valued
as much as other lives in this culture
I mean can you think of any example just
you know again we're talking about
history today historical precedence
just think of other and there are other
examples you could think of through
history
where it was considered controversial
to say that a certain group of people
had dignity or that their lives mattered
to speak up in defense of the you know
the inherent human dignity of a certain
group of people think of any time when
that's been considered controversial
has it ever been because everyone knows
that that group of people that they're
great and everything's fine
or is it because uh there is a
considered effort to dehumanize that
particular group of people
um and then and then of course we should
also note that of all the things that a
rappers say
and of course this is what they're upset
about white lives matter of all the
things that a rapper could say and the
many rappers do say Kanye West not as
much but other rappers
and this is what they're getting upset
about
so of course you know they can go out
there openly advocating to kids that
they use drugs kill people abuse women
that's that's not a dangerous message
but to say White lives matter well
that's dangerous yeah
all right this is uh
as you know we're on this we're just now
embarking on our screening tour for uh
what is a woman we're going to be going
to colleges all across the country
and we're starting we're here we're in
DC right now we'll be speaking at
Catholic University we have an update on
that not just speaking but screening the
movie and then we'll do a q a uh we have
an update on Catholic University but
first where we're going next is um the
University of Illinois
and so you have tweeted this yesterday
it says leftists have a battle plan in
place what they call battle plan quote
unquote to try and prevent Matt Walsh's
what is a woman tour at UIUC this
Thursday they're asking volunteers to be
Mischief Makers and plan to assemble a
massive trans pride flag in the audience
so this is what and then we'll put it up
on the screen you can see this is what
they're they're sending around the
activists
um I think they originally yeah they
originally posted this on Reddit
and it says um remind him
talking about me that Earth have no
space for transphobic
what was that remind him that Earth have
no space
remind him that Earth have no space
for transphobic
you don't have to be trans non-binary to
join because you two are a human being
you are very unlikely to get into
trouble
you can participate anonymously so what
are they planning to do they're going to
cause a Mischief during my q a this is
in a couple days
uh-oh I'm walking into some Mischief I'm
getting a little nervous about this you
know there's nothing I hate more than
Mischief so uh what is it okay well now
here's what they're doing they have it
they have it okay they have it all drawn
out here
I have to say that this drawing is I
mean my nine-year-old daughter literally
draws better pictures than this I should
have hired her they should have asked
her to help uh so battle plan
um the plan is assemble a massive trans
Pride flag in the audience
that's the whole plan
so I guess they want to like by wearing
certain colored shirts they want to make
a trans pride flag and then they and I
guess I'm going to come out and see the
trans pride flag
and burst into tears and run off the
stage I think that's what they're hoping
will happen
we'll see we'll see if it happens
um anyway if you're interested in
participating in this I want to tell you
what their their plan is so stage one uh
there's a sign up form and a and a so
there's you can go to a certain website
you can sign up to be a Mischief maker
because that's the thing about Mischief
Makers they always have sign up forms
yes you have to sign up to do mischief
um
uh stage two be a Mischief maker show up
at 7 pm
put on provided shirt
then return the shirt back to us
um stage three return the shirts
and it mentions again return the shirt
so they're very this is the funniest
thing about this to me is that they're
very clear they want the shirts back
they need their shirts back that's the
most important thing that's like stage
three four and five is make sure you
give the damn shirts back
um okay so that's what they're planning
to do and there is an update that was
this is just emailed to me and so I'm
looking at it right now on the spot here
um
and we're being told that
they canceled the counter protest is
canceled at Illinois okay so this is all
a big waste of time apparently this is
what they sent out this is what the
activists sent out Dear Mischief Makers
and accomplices
this email is for announcing that that
Thursday's Mischief has been officially
canceled
please do not bring t-shirts on Tuesday
or show up on Thursday night
the reason behind the prompt
cancellation has to do with a serious
logistic issues and B safety of
participants how can you have logistic
issues when all you're planning to do is
sit in the sit in the audience with with
blue and pink shirts on you have
logistic you you can't figure that
logistically
I am no logistical genius by any means
whatsoever but I could figure out how to
I'll help you okay you need my help I'll
I'm we can figure out a way to get
everyone the shirts they need for this
um what are the logistics we collected
more than 60 responses to show up during
the speech even though some responses
are just random responses the number of
participants is much higher than the
t-shirts available Which is less than 10
at the time of writing so they couldn't
get enough t-shirts you wanted to make a
trans pride flag in the audience you
only had 10 shirts how are you going to
make a whole flag with 10 shirts
and then also safety of participants
some responses in the signup form made
us worry about the safety of the
participants we fight and speak up yet
safety and mental well-being always come
first
so it sounds like my safety was actually
being jeopardized so these are these are
people on your side saying things that
make you worried about safety so isn't
that were they planning to hurt
themselves during the speech or were
they plan or were they saying things
that they're planning to hurt me
and you don't want to get in trouble for
that well I don't know but um
anyway
so they had their big protests and they
had to cancel it because they couldn't
find enough
landing and you couldn't come up with
shirts
you could just order a pack of them on
Amazon you could order a pack you could
order a pack of on Amazon for 20 bucks
you could end up pick a blue shirts for
everybody you'd have enough for eye that
I could wear one
oh my God
uh and then what's happening let's see
there's also an update that this is all
just sent to me right now I honestly
have not read it and uh so there's an
update on the Catholic University am I
about to find out right now that our
event was canceled and I'm here for no
reason uh so this email was sent out by
the president of the University
says as the Catholic University of
America we are often asked to defend or
explain our actions in terms of how they
stand up to what it means to be a
Catholic as an example last week I met
with a group of students who asked me to
consider censoring or canceling a
speaker invited by another group of
students whom they believe does not
reflect the values we hold this quarter
identity as a Catholic University uh
here we go
the argument made an impression on me
because it came from a sincere desire
which I shared to create on this campus
an inclusive and welcoming atmosphere
for all students the speaker they
asserted would make them feel unwelcome
and even unsafe while I do not want any
student to feel unwelcome or unsafe I
okay I couldn't agree to the request all
right well done sir uh and then he goes
on explaining why uh after consideration
he's decided not to cancel the event
and uh
but it's pretty long and he's you know
trying to reason with people and explain
that you know it's it's we want to hear
other people's points of view he doesn't
I don't think he mentions this uh
through the whole thing but
you know I am Catholic myself and
everything and no he does not say this
I'm Catholic myself everything I say on
the topic of gender and sex all of that
is 100 in keeping with Catholic teaching
100 percent
it's also in keeping with reality and
truth and uh you know so often all these
things line up together
which is the great thing about being
Catholic but anyway
um you know that's also something maybe
maybe it'd be worth mentioning
and I know I guess I'm supposed to give
Peter Kilpatrick credit for not
canceling the event which great but but
actually I don't give you credit for
that at all I'm not gonna thank you for
that because uh that's what I that's
expected
okay to cancel a Catholic speaker on a
Catholic campus who's who's talking
about the reality
uh and of of of biological sex
that would just be unacceptable and so
he is not doing the unacceptable thing
which is okay good
all right let's see one other thing that
we got
well this is important before we get to
the comment section um this is from NPR
this is only going to interest me so
I'm going to talk about it months of
Suspicion erupted into full-throated
Fury at a professional fishing
tournament in Ohio where two Anglers
were allegedly caught with egg-shaped
weights in their catch an edge of more
than seven pounds that would have
ensured a lucrative championship and
there's a video apparently of people
discovering this very dramatic video uh
We're not gonna play we could find it
online where they're doing the weigh-in
and uh and then they someone suspects
that there's weights in the fish they
cut the fish open you know
there's unfortunate for the fish and so
the fish get cut open and they pull the
weights out so they actually put lead
weights in the fish so they could um
win when they get to the weigh-in now as
an Avid Angler myself I have to say that
I'm totally disgusted and disappointed
that I never thought to do this because
that's that's actually pretty smart it
never even occurred to me that you could
put
weights in the fish's mouth to pump up
your stats a little bit but it is bad
it's cheating
it brings disgrace
to those of us who enjoy sitting around
for hours at a time stabbing hooks
through fishes and mouths for fun
it makes us even look a little bit weird
um which is to me what I am most angry
about
let's get to the comment section
Dalton says Dad and I went squirrel
hunting Sunday morning and I had a blast
even for a first time other than
spending time outdoors with my father
and learning firearm safety I kept in
the back of my head many of our leaders
um
I kept thinking I guess in the back of
my head many of our leaders would
despise my family for doing what we did
simply because it had a semblance of
toxic masculinity and making our leaders
even more upset pleases me to no extent
but yeah it's a it's a fulfilling uh
even leaving aside the fact that you're
you're killing those those innocent
precious squirrels
um which which actually in all
seriousness I mean I mean if you're
gonna go hunting that's that's probably
the best hunting you can do because
squirrels are
are a menace
um but even leaving that aside the fact
that you're spending quality time
as a family learning some important life
skills yeah that is that would upset the
powers that be in our culture
um
bursum bursum II says I've already
reached my quota for gay content I
binged a Netflix series about an iconic
lgbtq figure Dahmer great acting tight
writing and I suppose a good boost for
their representation uh yeah that's been
one controversy that you know we cover a
lot of the the really dumb controversies
on the show and and there are some that
even I
can't bring myself to care about even
enough to to talk about uh and that's
that's one of them but it is it is
pretty funny I mean I I have to admit
that so I guess Netflix has this
I don't know if it's a I guess it's not
a documentary it's a like a true crime
show mini series about Jeffrey Dahmer
the serial killer and I have an issue
with it because I just don't
uh
maybe there's a certain Gene that I lack
that other people have that makes them
really fascinated by serial killers and
there's this insatiable uh thirst that
people have to to
consume serial killer content and I
don't quite have it and I especially
like a mini series about a serial killer
I don't need to see
these people actually are not that
interesting right serial killers are uh
they're sociopaths
and they enjoy killing people I don't I
don't find it it's I don't find it
interesting like I don't need to spend
the idea of spending
five six seven eight nine ten hours
collectively
you know watching a story like that I
don't quite get it myself but
you know uh Netflix especially puts
these things out all the time people
love it uh but not in this case because
they represented you know Jeffrey Dahmer
is homosexual and they I guess that
comes out in the the show that he was a
homosexual and apparently Netflix even
labeled it at one point they labeled the
Jeffrey Dahmer serial killer show as
LGBT content they had that labels under
the LGBT category which is almost
funnier than my book Johnny The Walrus
uh being labeled in LGBT book almost
funnier but not quite and of course the
left got very upset about this they said
the we don't want that this is not LGBT
well he was gay you know so you want
representation oh we don't want that
representation
so you want you want representation of
only the good guys so you want that's
what you want you want well that's
that's not how it works
uh as the straight people we have good
guys we've got bad guys we've got them
all and uh so if you want is there two
sides to the coin and if you want
representation in film then you got to
take both sides of it and that means you
got to start claiming some of these
serial killers too you got to start
taking some of them some of them off our
hands
um
the Dirty Bubble says I'm very the Dirty
Bubble
I'm very happy to hear the movie Bros
has been a commercial failure YouTube
was pushing this film heavily in their
advertisements for a few weeks and
championing its critic rating as if it's
worth a damn uh yeah that's one of my
favorite things about the story also
it's just the whole thing is great the
whole thing is great
um the fact that the movie flopped so
spectacularly and I really can't we
talked about it yesterday but I cannot
emphasize enough just how much of a
failure this film actually was to make
less than five million dollars in an
opening weekend they made half a million
on opening night okay 500 000. less than
5 million over a whole opening weekend
when you've got all that marketing
pushed behind it and the media is behind
it is just a
catastrophic failure and it's hilarious
so I love that
um
I love the fact that Billy Eichner the
star of the film is just watching him if
you don't have a Twitter account get a
Twitter account this week because the
best thing happening on social media
this week and probably for this decade
is Billy Eichner trying to cope with the
fact that nobody wanted to see his gay
sex film he he cannot cope with it he
can't deal with it and he's just lashing
out and it gets more unhinged by the day
it's great
um
and also
when you see how the critics especially
are flabbergasted by this
because they keep saying well we we said
it's good we told you guys the movie's
good we told you to go watch it you
didn't watch it
so the media can't understand it doesn't
compute
to say if you go to Rotten Tomatoes the
movie has a 300 frustrating Rotten
Tomatoes it's the best thing they've
ever seen right
and yet no one cares no no one in the
movie going audience cares what the
critics say and so they're trying to
cope with that there's a lot of cope
going on and it's just great
do you want to win a McLaren or 250 000
in cash I'm talking to all the dads
right now as a father we all want what's
best for our children and their
education
um well I would never want my kid to own
McLaren what is it where is this going
well I wouldn't want to have 250 000
either but that's why we sometimes
begrudgingly but still enthusiastically
participate in school fundraisers from
buying magazines to bacon cookies to
paying a bunch of kids to half wash our
vehicles at the team Car Wash well what
if you could spearhead the biggest
fundraiser in your school and communist
history with less effort than a
walkathon okay all right I do agree with
this by now you've likely heard of
Jeremy's razors uh the contest for the
car where you might become the winner of
Jeremy's McLaren now short you could add
a 592 horsepower Supercar to your
School's bus fleet or you could opt for
the 250 000 cash prize instead you and
all the other dads and moms could do a
lot of good for your kids with that
money just by referring a few non-woke
razors imagine quarter million dollars
to resurface the gym build a computer
room put up some Friday Night Lights
right now most of the top players in the
contest still haven't hit 10 referrals
Mark so the field is wide open for you
to wait at all go to the principal's
office get him or her involved and head
to Jeremy's razors.com play to get your
referral link and get in the game now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we turn
to the guardian which published an
article on Saturday with this title and
uh subheading how gay Parenthood through
surrogacy became a Battleground in New
York a gay couple fighting to make their
insurers pay for fertility treatment
have found themselves in the middle of a
culture War what happens when the right
to Parenthood involves someone else's
body
well I can answer that question what
happens or what should happen anyway is
that you realize that nobody has a right
to Parenthood in the first place the
very notion of a right to Parenthood is
not only bizarre and unintelligible but
also ripe with all sorts of very dark
implications
but something tells me that that's not
the answer to the question that we're
going to get from this piece so let's
read on it says Corey briskin and
Nicholas Magi Pinto met in law school in
2011 were engaged by 2014 and had their
2016 wedding announced in the New York
Times They moved to a waterfront
apartment Block in Williamsburg Brooklyn
with a bright playroom for families on
the ground floor quote we got married
and then we wanted all the trappings
house children 401K Etc Magi Pinto 37
tells me and they're building shared
meeting room tapping the table in
sequence with the progression of each
idea briskin 33 grew up assuming he'd
have children he came out in college
quote once I had come out to myself and
others I don't think my expectation of
what my life would look like changed all
that much with marriage equality one
years ago they expected to be able to
have a conventional married life
yes the laws changed which led these two
men to assume that they would be able to
have a biological child
a change in the law was supposed to also
result in a change to fundamental human
biology apparently
that's what they expected and it didn't
turn out that way tragically for them
reading against us six months before
their wedding a targeted ad from an
organization called Gay parents to be
landed in Magi Pinto's Instagram feed
offering free consultations with a
fertility doctor who'd give them the
whole rundown on how they could start a
family quote we had the same appointment
and we were 100 on the same page let's
move forward with this I've met I Pinto
that's when they first became aware of
the eye watering costs of biological
Parenthood for gay men
Magi Pinto uh reels off the price list
in a way that only someone who's poured
over every item could there's
compensation for the egg donor no less
than eight thousand dollars the egg
donor agency fee fee eight thousand ten
thousand dollars the fertility clinics
Bill including genetic testing blood
test STD screening and a psychiatric
evaluation for all parties sperm testing
egg extraction insemination the growing
selecting freezing implication of the
resulting embryos up to seventy thousand
dollars and that's if it all goes well
if no embryos are created during a cycle
or if the embryos that are don't lead to
a successful pregnancy they would have
to start again
okay I feel like I must have interject
here um to correct
the record these are not the costs of
biological Parenthood for gay men as
though there's some sort of special up
charge based on your sexual orientation
these are the costs of trying to usurp
and evade nature during the child
conception process
um for two men the costs are even
steeper because they not only must
conceive a child in a Petri disk but
they also must rent a woman's womb
literally purchasing her body to be used
as property
and along with being a morally horrific
practice it's also very expensive
so the expense is the only thing that
mattered to these two narcissists they
don't appear to have stopped to consider
the ethical implications at all
it continues then there's the cost of a
surrogate called a gestational carrier
when the kid when they carry embryos
created for another woman's eggs
Magi pinto and briskin were told agency
fees alone could stretch to twenty five
thousand dollars and the surrogates
themselves could be paid a minimum of
sixty thousand dollars it takes 15
minute uh minutes for magic Pinto to run
me through all the expenses
they could incur if they tried to have a
child genetically related to one of them
the bottom line two hundred thousand
dollars minimum he says tapping his
indexed finger on the table with each
word in disbelief they couldn't afford
it Magi Pinto earns a corporate lawyer's
salary but is saddled with student debt
brisket used to work for the City of New
York as an assistant district attorney
earning about 75 000 a year okay
yes who could find a more oppressed
victim group
then two gay lawyers in New York
well I mean literally anyone could find
a more oppressed victim group I cannot
think of a group less oppressed
than gay lawyers in New York
but don't worry they are working to
rectify this Injustice they're suing the
city of New York so that in their so
that their IDF and surrogacy will be
covered under the City's health
insurance plan in other words they want
to create a baby and purchase a woman's
womb and they want the taxpayers to fund
it
as one of them says in a line quoted in
the headline of the article they can't
be expected to be okay with not having
children
even though even though that they are
two men
and they literally cannot have children
together not by my decree or by the law
but by the decree of nature
they still shouldn't be expected to be
okay with it they say
um it's the duty of the taxpayer or the
insurance companies to subsidize
whatever elaborate morally problematic
work around they can devise that's their
position
and it's completely absurd of course
now commercial surrogacy to begin with
is a barbarous practice which is why
it's illegal in many countries Across
the Western world except in the United
States of course
that's one thing I think people don't
often realize or appreciate is that so
often our laws
are far more leftist and liberal than
than Europe I mean we tend to think of
Europe as the kind of Farther Along on
the on the left-wing crazy train and
maybe in some ways culturally they are
but when it comes to laws abortion law
is another one
um uh their their laws are much more
conservative than ours
so um in in many countries
for-profit commercial surrogacy is
illegal and even not-for-profit
surrogacy what they call quote are
altruistic sir surrogacy is also banned
in many countries including Germany
Portugal Italy Spain
why well because surrogacy is a moral
crime against both women and children
the woman is rented her actual body her
reproductive capacity is put under a
contract to its purchase for temporary
use like an Airbnb it is dehumanizing
even if the woman is paid for it
in fact especially if she's paid for it
it's dehumanizing
and in most cases such as would be the
case with the two oppressed gay New York
Lawyers a second woman's body is also
auctioned off as she has to provide the
eggs to conceive the child who's then
and then and then and then that's
implanted into the rented womb of
another
the two men who wish to have biological
children
have almost nothing to do with the
process
except to provide the sperm for the
petri dish
and it should be noted that only one man
provides the sperm so that even after
all this effort
still the male couple will not have a
biological child so this whole thing is
about gay couples who want to have
biological children they still can't
they can't
one member of the couple will have a
biological child while some other woman
who neither of them know and uh and who
the child will never know is is the
other person who creates the child
and that brings us to the child who um
you may have noticed never faxes factors
into the calculation at all the two
dudes talk about me I we us me me me but
they never at any point mention the
well-being of the child who they're
trying to conceive
the child who will forever be deprived
of knowing his mother he will never know
the woman who gave him life he will
never know the woman who harbored him in
her womb and birthed him
he will only know the men who bought him
the man who they believe have a right to
him
and that's exactly why there is no right
to Parenthood and never can be what kind
of confused world do we live in when
Society does not recognize a parent's
right to raise their own children that
they actually conceived but it does
recognize a gay couple's right to
conceive children in the first place
such a right cannot exist rights okay if
if they mean anything
human rights must be natural ingrained
in our human nature you cannot have a
right over and above and against nature
you cannot make a rights claim against
nature
so two men claiming that they have a
right to conceive it's like two men
claiming they have a right to breathe
underwater like a fish
and with technical technological
assistance you can breathe underwater
not exactly like a fish but you can get
by
um underwater for a time a pale
limitation but it may be you know enough
to get the job done yet it doesn't make
any sense to say that you have a right
to do it
our rights are not a list of all the
things that we can physically do with or
without technology
the main reason you can't have a right
to Parenthood is that Parenthood
requires the participation of other
people and in the case of two gay men it
requires a whole Army of other people a
whole Battalion doctors and scientists
and multiple women willing to sell parts
of their bodies and agencies and
everything else to say they have a right
to Parenthood is to say that all of
these other people are obliged to
provide them with their Parenthood
opportunity
it is to in a sense morally conscript
these other parties to give you what
nature would not
your right becomes an obligation for
others you're right in other words
becomes the removal of Rights for others
imagine if a gay couple
um could could uh couldn't find a woman
willing to rent out her womb or sell her
eggs
if the couple has a right to Parenthood
then it must be said that these women
are infringing on the couple's right by
not providing their bodies for usage
these two men are literally declaring
that they have a right to a woman's body
because that's what it means as a gay
man if you're saying you have a right to
biological Parenthood you are saying you
have a right to a woman's body which is
exactly the sort of thing that the left
is always screaming about
only in this case it's actually
happening and the people who scream
about it are silent
or else cheering it alone
which is hypocrisy in the extreme
par for the course
but we still must say
that Corey briskin
Nicholas Magi Pinto be oppressed gay
lawyers from New York
only to add to their oppression today
are canceled
and that will do it for us today we move
over to the members block I hope to see
you there if not talk to you tomorrow or
I'll see you at Catholic University
tonight Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]